pourquoi une nouvelle rubrique
et pourquoi mémoire du zinc à je sais
pas si vous êtes comme moi mais moi j'ai
eu envie en recevant des invités d'en
savoir plus sur plus sur l'hormone qui
sont leur travail plus seront leurs
univers mais comment faire alors on sait
dès que si on proposait à notre invité
les différentes rubriques qui composent
notre émission à savoir un échec et mat
ping-pong passion d'auteur journal
intime
on avait peut-être une chance de le
guider et de l'aider à constituer sa
mémoire du zinc
c'est ce que nous allons faire ce soir
avec notre invité jean louis murat
bonsoir bonsoir alors est ce que vous
avez écrit ce matin
oui oui tous les matins 6h15 bavilliers
scellier je lis avant j'ai créé près we
lire avant par exemple en ce moment
c'est quoi le livre de chevet je suis
sur sodome et gomorrhe de brousse de
france alors oui si vous êtes
inconscient oui beaucoup énormément
évolué à vis à vis à vis donc chaque
matin donc cette hygiène as aussi
l'hygiène du corps et sportif
oui c'est moi c'est donc
les longs mois tout au vélo j'ai vu je
sais même que vous pleurez qu'environ
fleurs mais je m'y attache beaucoup
votre sentiment oui un poids si tu lis
qui tombe ça me gêne importante chute et
moi-même et s'équivaut grand séjour
bahamontès seghers électro classique que
c'est celle que j'aime les grands champs
qui emmène donc j'aime j'aime j'ai la
chance de connaître il nous faut par
exemple nous pouvons utile mais j'aime
beaucoup aussi lance armstrong
oui j'ai exactement le même équipement
que lance amstrong pas je me suis fait
faire sur mesure le même vélo donc
jamais jamais les champions ou bonbons
on va quitter le tour de france pour
parler quand même de cet album on va
écouter la chanson premier 45 voyez le
premier caillou km a donc que l'on va
écouter qui tourne qui a qu'à cette
vertu et cette force hypnotique un petit
peu partout autour et qu'il a eue sur
moi et piétons kylie
paquet
si vous
mais ça
yu
[Musique]
qui ne
apparemment
baduel
m
je sais que vous comme vous le dites
parfois vous pourriez écrire un album
break sur un nom sur
bien sûr terminator minaj est qu un
album non non bien sûr
on le sait très bien je pense que si en
effet familier avec les mots avec les
phrasés avec l'imagination on s'éteint
famille il suffit d'appuyer sur un
bouton
c'est un monde magique on élimine carole
c'est l'ancien testament qui s'ouvre sur
un seul nom
un seul mot ce qui fait un album ce sont
les chansons elle et elle les chansons
est-ce que par contre l'état dans ce qui
fait un album qui fait un album c'est la
personne qui écrit l'album et qu'une le
change donc plutôt la force et la
constance et la tenue que peut avoir la
personne qui réalise tous les ans un
nouvel album assez poussée mais est ce
qu a pas un thème est ce que pareil on
termina à une couleur chaude jamais là
le thème c'est moi c'est à dire que
c'est moi le thème c'est mes états d'âme
je pense que ce qui est essentiellement
c
la mort la peur la peur de mourir et le
spectacle déjà encore de moi qui meurt
et disparaissent c'est surtout ça le
thème du disco show est ce que le fait
d'être jeune papa ça accroît la peur de
l'amour oui en l'occurrence c'est vrai
que je me dis tiens
ma nouvelle petite fille me verra mourir
jeu peut-être bien qu'elle me fermera
les yeux
donc effectivement ça
ça ajoute une sorte de d'inciter aux
réflexions qu'on peut avoir sur soi même
c'est justine et à la deux ans et demi
alors on va donc passer à l'organisation
de différentes séquences toujours en
parlant de votre travail bien sûr
puisque en fait ces séquences sont là
pour parler de vous alors notre échec et
mat
on utilise cette petite pendule pour
mettre deux personnes face à face pour
discuter d'un sujet qui préoccupe ou qui
peut énerver vous quels sujets vous avez
choisi de traiter contre quoi je crois
même déchaînée contre les journalistes
les journalistes parce qu'on se demande
toujours par quel phénomène est ce que
quel phénomène peut-il bien se passer
pour que les gens nous explique journaux
c'est ce qu'ont constaté moi qui suis au
contact des gens et ce outre la journée
ça me paraît assez simple c'est qu'ils
sont nuls les journées sont nulles et
effectivement ils fabriquent des
journaux qui sont assez nul et les gens
les lisent pas et vous êtes bien servi
par la presta moi j'ai eu et j'ai eu à
votre caisse qu'on appelle bien servi
non bien servi en tout cas la quantité
je pense que vous ayez l'intelligence et
la quantité des gens profitent et si
vous recevez des cendres enfin je pense
qu'il sent tellement de mauvaises
qualités que tient
un sentiment de défiance du public si
vous avez beaucoup de presse les gens se
méfient se disent tiens ya beaucoup de
presse prévient qu'il est mauvais comme
un cochon suis là mais ils soyons clair
vous avez vous êtes à lui mais de par
l'histoire est bien naturel
oui parce que c'est comparer bien-être
mathieu bien sûr je soutiens donc
qu'est-ce qui vous êtes vous insurger
contre toi contre la nullité des
journalistes en général de la main c'est
que je pense qu'effectivement entre les
gens et le monde comme il va
les journalistes se font une sorte de
ce sont des sortes de fusible de
transmetteurs de médias effectivement
et/ou de médium et qu' ils ne font pas
leur boulot ce qui fait qu'on a
l'impression que le que le monde est un
chiotte boucher et c'est simplement que
je trouve que les journalistes sont
vraiment pas leur boulot
donc ça c'était pour le côté je
m'insurge alors le ping-pong qui est
matérialisée par cette petite balle que
je vous confie qui est donc est ce qu'il
y a
un article à une critique qu'on a faites
vous qui vous à laquelle vous aimeriez
répond eh bien au contraire
un éloge qu'on a fait de vous que vous
aimeriez salué une pompe c'est cette
occasion là qu'est ce que je peux le
dire si avant-hier j'ai un
un message téléphonique de gérard manset
à la maison oui oui ce genre on vous
compare tous et partout
oui c'était très gentil ça faisait 25
ans et débats parler
alors voilà vous avez pensé essayé de
dire quelque chose de positif c'est que
j'ai pas répondu mais cet échantillon
qu'est ce que vous lui diriez vous
écoute forcément tout le monde regarde
café picouly
oui bien sûr non jeu vidéo ces gentilles
me frapper je vais bien ma balle depuis
le temps que j'ai ma réponse alors
passion d'auteur là va trouver quelqu'un
dont on a envie de parler miroir en main
et dont on aimerait dire pendant une
minute ou deux du bien ou simplement
parler l'évoqué un auteur contemporain
puis on veut ça peut trouver comme ça
peut être
non je peux pas vraiment sortir de mars
oui je veux pas vraiment sentir bien
seul je vous parle de ce que j'ai lu ce
matin oui défini l'amitié comme quelque
chose entre la fatigue et l'ennui
j'aime beaucoup ça fasse en deux
la façon menti
quand il s'attaque à nietzsche dans le
défaut d'amitié qui reproche à wagner en
considérant qu'une amitié doit être
aussi un intellectuel il pousse de quand
est-ce que ça je fais énormément
confiance à proust pour mon inconscient
de deux petits mecs français et
et je sais que peut-être les mois des
mois à venir je vais beaucoup réfléchir
à cette idée là de l'amicale vous avez
été déçu en amitié toujours toujours pas
d'exception si j'ai un ami
mais comme les véritables âmes y en a
partout alors on n'en parle pas je
reprends un miroir de patients il dit
avoir vu passer passion notter journal
intime
alors pour ce journal intime donc je
vais voir à cette petite caméra que je
vous mets dans la main et j'aimerais je
vous en ai parlé on a parlé entre papa
de justice justin je sais que vous allez
lui me construire une cabane comme oui
pour l'été prochain pour l'été prochain
moi j'aimerais que vous emmener dans
cette cabale dire comment elle va être
vous le fils de menuisier
ouais elle va être déjà une sécurité
totale au fait que les enfants tombent à
huy dans un arbre de survie bien sûr à
être énorme être d'être un être qui au
moins 200 jours et qu est la première
chose qu'on va y faire écouter les
oiseaux observer les nuages apprendre à
donner des noms en nuage c'est moussa
chose comme sa blessure et après
repérez la direction du vent
suivre l'avis des failles mais bon j'en
jusqu'à la feuille morte pourquoi est-ce
que la feuille morte parce qu est ce que
le papa arbres d'un seul coup se dit
petites feuilles ça y est tu as fait ton
temps je me sépare de toi donc là
puisque le vent devient le devient l'ami
de la petite feuille qui sont pop a dit
bon maintenant c'est fini ma petite
enfin je sais pas le savoir ce que c'est
ce que c'est qu'un art parce que c'est
la vie dans un arbre en tout cas alors
quand quand on entend ce rapport tout le
monde me dit vous avez un rapport à la
nature et pourtant on lit dans certains
endroits vous avez eu envie de partir
souvent je suis partir pour mieux
revenir une entente hier pour mieux
revenir
si vous voulez ça n'a pas de sens de
rester de rester toujours de rester
toujours au même endroit le ccc comme
tous et comme c'est comme les sentiments
ses formes de va-et-vient de va et vient
qui équipe qui en lui-même procure le
plaisir sert de s'éloigner et de revenir
bien sûr c'est donc j'aime beaucoup de
jeunes je suis enraciné
mais la racine m'en prend du sens parce
que je voyage vous êtes d'accord avant
très bien je reprends la caméra juste et
ne t'inquiète pas cette cabane sera bien
belle et e
je vous offrirai un livre pour la cavale
de justo merci je suis alors resté sur
cette parole a rappelé taormina votre
dernier avant de dire que vous êtes en
tournée à partir de quand à partir
d'octobre
à partir d'octobre puisque décembre
puisque jusque décembre que bien sûr je
conseille à tout le monde d'écouter et
d'aller au-delà de cette très belle
chanson qui tourne actuellement mais
entrer dans cet album
voilà n'en restait pas aux cailloux qui
est déjà une belle chose
en tout cas moi je suis très heureux de
vous avoir rencontré comme ça m'a fait
très plaisir même chose pour moi je
prends bien suivi d'assez de chanter
[Musique]